morning will you stay a while little
while
but not to worry
I'll see you at the christening and go
hello beast
I missed you you tried with a little
less fun of this so very kind of you to
invite me this evening
better not with the curtsy
let's get that part
well I'm queen of the moles and I am
human
on the side
[Applause]
well there are many who prey on the
innocent I'm sure your kind would agree
mark island she means humans can we just
listen to the music I remember the story
of a baby a baby
cursed to sleep and never wake up really
who would do such a terrible thing to an
innocent child well there are many who
prey on the innocent I'm sure your
client would agree what do you mean my
kind she means humans there are fairies
missing from the Moors what I'm missing
is some wine
stolen by human poachers that's the
first I've heard of it someone gave the
order
you
you
[Music]
now we will have a wall
what about Maleficent our fight begins
now our fight begins now
Conan wanted peace and they filled him
with Bayern now we will have our war
Oh
hey and I think the necklace cries now
[Music]
you
maybe she's right know it everyone
especially the king what about
Maleficent
[Music]
oh yeah like don't like this
[Music]
you
absolutely
I want sure it's perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the night
[Music]
did you like a little pricey yoohoo
guess the nominee they're on their gun
crazy comedy
it's so funny with them in the modern
world like polar
[Applause]
[Music]
you
so you can do better when you do very
well very well
I
when when Pinto comes closer we need to
come JIP down on the on the army
I think budget I mean this one we see
ghosts we should book what we don't and
then we have been open up Aurora
[Music]
she walks
my opening